welcome to this breaking news debate
edition of Hannity tonight let's set the
record straight there are no moderates
that are running for president in the
modern Democratic radical extreme
socialist party they're not here either
more radical or less radical but you're
still radical and you're still a
socialist now the narrative from fake
news CNN and MSDN see about a
politically diverse set of candidates
that's just the newest lie after two and
a half years of line they all support
some version of this insane new green
deal and they all support raising your
taxes and they all support
government-run universal health care and
by the way guess what they want free
health care for illegal immigrants and
building walls is immoral they all want
to buy into the lie or you to buy into
the lie keep your doctor keep your plan
and save less but this is on human
growth hormones and steroids and it's
applied to every aspect of our economy
and if we have no oil or gas it will
destroy this economy in weeks not even
months the impact will be felt
immediately I've got a lot to say on
this we're going to show you the very
worst moments from both debates
spoiler alert socialism has infected
every corner of the Democratic Party and
2020 will be the biggest choice election
in our lifetime this is a tipping point
for the country anyone that doesn't tell
you that is not telling you the truth
it's that dire now we'll leave the
continue down the path of freedom
constitutional government prosperity
capitalism you know risk reward with
President Trump well we will plunge into
the depths of Soviet style big
government economic tyranny and poverty
will immediately follow thereafter
highlights reaction are just minutes
away before I get to my monologue we
have some major breaking news
surrounding mr. super Patriot himself
Jim Comey our friends at judicial watch
have just obtained some very compelling
documents a little old Jimbo well that
he probably doesn't want you to see
order to know about as it turns out in
June of 2017
one month after Comey was fired well the
FBI people that he used to be the boss
of agents showed up at his door why
didn't we find this out sooner
they were there to retrieve his
classified government memos that he was
storing in his home which is illegal
the agents also grilled call me about
documents during an interview by the way
that would be called an interrogation
for the rest of the world and keep in
mind is the very same memos about his
confidential communications with the
President of the United States
call me leak those to the media through
a professor friend of his at Columbia it
for the purpose of spurring a Special
Counsel investigation now mr. super
Patriot Comey never should have had
those documents at his house and oh yeah
leaking classified material is a crime
now I don't think this is his biggest
crime in my humble opinion
I've told super Patriot Jim called me
many times before I'll say it again
tonight Jim you have the right to remain
silent my advice now more than ever you
need to shut up take my advice
none of us now with more judicial watch
president tom Fitton
this is a big discovery and I'll be
honest as as far as the sins of Jim
Comey and things that I think are
important the legality issues of it this
this is you know the low-hanging fruit
this is the least important what he did
on FISA and elsewhere will be far more
important to the American people over
time well it's part of a piece and Comey
took the FBI files he had on President
Trump kept them at his home which was
illegal taking someone's FBI files and
keeping them at your home and he used
them for political purposes he leaked
them to the New York Times to get a
special counsel and a coincidentally his
friend Robert Muller gets appointed look
no leak of the memos no Muller special
counsel so this is a pretty big deal and
now we know for the first time the FBI
was investigating his creation and
handling of these memos and it's a month
after he's fired they show up at his
house they're interviewing him and he
says look I have these memos you want
him come on guys the FBI let these
records walk out the door which is a
violation of president Trump's rights he
keeps him there at his house he doesn't
tell them that he's leaking them he
admits to it the next day
in congressional testimony it's a
keystone kops atmosphere but
unfortunately the president's the victim
here and the president's the victim of
several crimes in my view committed by
Comey in terms of taking his FBI files
which is illegal and then leaking them
and that created the Special Counsel
investigation even more so than the FISA
warrants abusive as it was as abusive as
they were all right tom Fitton
we're going to continue to watch
Judicial Watch all these Freedom of
Information Act requests this is
important I have a funny feeling and my
sources are telling me it's going way
further than that